And the answer is we will use a
return-address stack, which is a separate predictor, dedicated
to predicting function returns. The way it works
is that we have a small stack in hardware,
with a pointer. As we execute the program, when we have a function call, we will
push the return address, in this case 123. 0 is the address of the call, so 1234
would be the return address. To the return
address stack, and move the pointer. In the function,
when we encounter the return instruction, we will
pop from this return address stack and use the
1234 to return, and in that case, get
the correct target address. Now, our pointer is here,
we don't really have to delete this entry
because the pointer being here means that it's free.
Next, when we reach the next place where the function
is called from, we will see the return address, in this
case, 1254, on to the return address stack. The function
executes when we see the return instruction. We pop the return
address and we again predict correctly. So why is this
a predictor? Why not just use the actual stack of the
program? Well because this predictor needs to be on a
chip very close to where the rest of the branch prediction
is happening and needs to be very, very small.
So unlike your traditional stack, where you would push something
onto this stack. Call another function from there, call a
nested function. And you can do that many many times
until you run out of memory. In this particular case,
we can have very small hardware structure so that it
can make a prediction very quickly, like in one cycle.
Thus it can only have a limited number of entries.
So what happens when we exceed the size of the
RAS? Let's say we have only four entries. Let's say
that we call a function. Call another one. We call
another one. We call another one. And now, the question
is what do we do? So if our RAS is
full, what do we do? There are really two choices.
One, don't push anything. Pretty much preserve what we already
have on the RAS, so that we don't overwrite anything.
The other choice is, once we have filled these four entries,
just wrap around and keep filling them if we call more functions.